[Música]
y
los lugares de culto religioso fueron
parte de los sectores más afectados por
la cuarentena estricta implementada en
venezuela por la pandemia del cob y 19
debido a que sus actos masivos fueron
suspendidos desde marzo y todavía se
desconoce cuándo volverán a abrir sus
puertas la iglesia católica a través de
la conferencia episcopal ya hizo el
protocolo para la vuelta a los templos
pero sin la autorización sigue
transmitiendo misas online también ha
implementado auto misa y uno que otro
barrio residencial los curas desde las
azoteas dan el sermón a los vecinos que
se encuentran en las ventanas de sus
edificios la comunidad judía también
está haciendo actividades virtuales y
restos en su mínima expresión por el
cierre de las sinagogas los testigos de
jehova predican por whatsapp llamadas y
cartas y de igual manera los cristianos
evangélicos mantienen el contacto con
sus seguidores a la distancia para hacer
entrenamientos y conferencias y en
algunas comunidades hacen reunión de
cuatro personas con distanciamiento
social
[Música]
la pandemia ha logrado lo que no hizo la
larga y sangrienta guerra contra irak en
la década de los 80 y fue la cancelación
de la oración de los viernes
especialmente en teherán en un régimen
donde la política y la religión están
absolutamente ligados este es el espacio
a través de el cual el sistema manda a
sus mensajes a la población y tuvo que
cancelarlos desde marzo y si bien se han
ido recuperando poco a poco en algunas
de las grandes capitales de provincia
del país no se ha hecho en teherán donde
la situación del cobi 19 sigue estando
bastante preocupante de hecho es una
ciudad que está en alerta roja esto no
significa que el resto de mezquitas
estén cerradas se han ido reabriendo
poco a poco pero con todas las medidas
del protocolos de seguridad con
distanciamiento social y lo que ha
sucedido con las grandes conmemoraciones
religiosas es intentar que se hagan al
aire libre y manteniendo la distancia
social aunque no siempre ha sido exitoso
[Música]
tras varios meses de lucha hay una gran
manifestación en la iglesia católica le
ha ganado el pulso a la ciudad de san
francisco que recientemente ha permitido
la apertura de los lugares de culto
aunque eso sí con capacidad de no más de
100 fieles en cada misa para el
arzobispo de la iglesia católica de aquí
en san francisco salvatori core de lyon
en esta cifra no es suficiente y ahora
le exige al gobierno de california que
les permitan ampliar el número de fieles
que acuden a cada misa de hecho el mes
pasado hubo una gran manifestación aquí
en en san francisco con más de 3000
fieles que salieron a exigir al gobierno
de california que les permita abrir los
lugares de culto de hecho también se
celebraron varias docenas de misas de
manera ilegal
el arzobispo salvatore corleone acaba de
iniciar también el movimiento llamado
liberar a la misa para pedirle
precisamente esto al gobierno de
california
[Música]